Hey, David, why are the most dangerous cities
run by Democrats?
So this is a pretty old trope.
And I maybe we can kind of address this piece
by piece.
Donald Trump and Republicans have been harping
on this a lot.
Democrat run cities are riddled with violence.
So vote for me instead of Joe Biden, even
though, of course, Trump is already president.
And there's still violence in
those cities.
So here's what there's a few things you have
to understand.
Most cities are run by Democrats.
Period.
So violent cities are run by Democrats and
nonviolent cities are run by Democrats to
use crass terminology.
Additionally, the violence is disproportionately
in urban areas.
So when you think about cities instead of
areas, you start to get this talking point
that Trump has been repeated.
So if you look at mayors, 35 of the 50 largest
cities are run by Democrats.
13 are run by Republicans.
And two are Democratic leaning independents.
So because more cities are run by Democrats,
you have to account for that in your analysis.
The large Republican cities are San Antonio,
I'm sorry, San Diego, run by Republican mayor,
San Diego, Jacksonville.
Jacksonville is more dangerous than the average
in Florida.
It's run by a Republican.
Fort Worth, Texas, run by a Republican.
Is it more dangerous than the average of Texas
in terms of crime rates?
El Paso, Texas, is safer than average for
Texas.
Oklahoma City run by a Republican.
More dangerous than average.
So what you really just have to understand
is that there is a sort of base rate bias
that you do you have to account for.
The largest cities run by Democrats are the
largest cities in the country.
Crime tends to be greater in places with large
population density for a number of different
reasons that we understand cities have more
crime because they're more densely populated.
Cities also vote more for Democrats because
they are more cosmopolitan.
Higher education rates, we know more educated
people tend to vote for Democrats instead
of Republicans.
And that does not directly linked to the crime
is because the mayor is a Democrat and this
has been widely debunked
and it doesn't even pass the sniff test.
There is not actually any correlation between
crime and Democrat Democratic mayors when
you can't account for crime being more prevalent.
In cities and the fact that Democrats lead
a majority of the cities in the United States,
including cities with low crime rates.
Now when you look at the South, for example,
and the south at both the city and state level
is disproportionately under Republican rule.
They have some of the highest poverty rates
in the United States.
Does that mean that Republican rule causes
poverty?
Maybe it does.
And that's a better argument, quite frankly,
than crime and so-called Democrat cities.
But you still have to look at details and
understand more to really know what it is
that is going on.
Now, when this conversation comes up, we also
shouldn't ignore a broader context about crime.
That crime
has been decreasing for decades overall, and
we might be better served understanding that.
And also looking at areas rather than just
cities.
What Republicans do is they shift the focus
to cities rather than areas.
And that allows them to play on these bigoted,
racist ideas that the city is filled with
these scary minorities who are going to rob
you and sexually assault you and sort of like
the Willie Horton ad type of mentality.
What that shifts attention away from is the
reality that Republican dominated areas have
violent crime, that on a per capita basis
is just as bad as a lot of the city's cities
have more people and have more population
density.
So you are going to see more crime in sort
of an absolute sense.
So when Trump talks about the number of shootings
in a city, those are not per capita numbers.
And in order to really assess this, you have
to zoom out a little bit and look at areas
rather than just cities and of course, cities
overwhelmingly run by Democrats because Democrats
tend to be more interested in being in cities.
It really throws the entire idea in the trash.
Now, one other thought about this.
Even if let me see how to say this the right
way.
Even if on a per capita basis, there was less
violent crime in Republican run areas than
Democratically run areas.
It ignores the fact that people in the Republican
areas suffer in many other ways as well.
Right.
Economic deprivation is disproportionately
in the United States in Republican run areas.
Now, on a population, on a raw numbers basis,
they are less populated areas.
But on a per capita basis, if you look at
economic deprivation, underinvestment in government,
bad, terrible
resources, bad infrastructure, you know, all
the stuff, you see it on a per capita basis,
disproportionately in Republican areas.
And that's important to bring into the conversation
as well, although it's like who I'm talking
to, you guys.
The people that just repeat violent Democrat
cities aren't willing to hear this.
So there are those are a few thoughts.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com or a patron
at Patrie on
ICOM slash
David Pakman show.